going to school is boring most of the
time we have all gone through this this
is why we understand why someone would
vandalize their textbook during their
least favorite class to put a smile on
our face and just because we're talking
about school we'll also have some fun
facts to tell you just wait until you
see how someone saw the human body if
this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 15 examples of
genius textbook vandalism by bored
students that can almost be forgiven
pretty woman we know that teenagers have
a lot of hormones we have all been there
and this guy just couldn't stay focused
in math class he was so obsessed with a
girl that he liked he just kept seeing
her everywhere including his math
textbook you might not think that it
looks like anything but we were
surprised to see this young artist
transform it into a curvy woman is that
the formula for the perfect body
actually you might be surprised to know
that you'll need mathematics when it
comes to calculating the perfect female
body start by dividing the size of your
waists with the size of your hips and if
the number is between a point 67 and
point 8 you have the perfect ratio no
matter what size you are and if you
don't have the right number remember
that most people don't like mathematics
anyway just give them your phone number
instead and make sure you're not as thin
as the lady on the drawing Mario
Brothers one of the first things that we
like to do when we go back home is to
play video games and it seems like this
guy had one thing on his mind when he
transformed this person into his
favorite video game character you all
recognize him it's Mario Brothers with
the red hat and the big mustache but
school is a place where you read books
and this is how you could learn crazy
things that you never knew before did
you know that Mario is actually evil if
you read the Super Mario Brothers
instruction guide you'll learn that the
Koopa Stern the inhabitants of the
Mushroom Kingdom
into bricks and we all know that Mario
likes to destroy them so instead of
saving all these nice mushrooms we were
actually getting rid of them this is
probably the most evil plan Bowser ever
had but we have to admit that no one
reads the instruction guide the
sometimes we don't understand what
people were thinking when they were
making the textbooks because we saw some
really weird things just look at the
hair of this man it looks like something
that happened with a blow dryer that
morning and he decided to pose for a
photo shoot for the textbook anyway this
is what inspired a little story this
time the student thinks that the man
actually had a bird on his head and that
he just started flying away this is why
he ran to catch it but do you know why
people lose their hair something as
common as stress can shock the hair
cycle and push more hair into the
shedding phase however you won't see the
effect now but three to six months after
the trauma if it's only caused by stress
your hair will usually grow back that's
a good reason to relax at the spa
instead of going to the hairstylist
witchcraft
after watching Harry Potter we all
wanted to go to Hogwarts then we turned
11 and we didn't get our letter and we
think that the only thing that could
explain this is that the owl got lost
and will be coming home ten years later
there is no way someone is going to tell
us that we are not wizards and some
students were lucky enough to study
witchcraft in high school muggles might
say that it was simply a first aid class
but wizards knew that they were actually
learning spells to make people come back
to life and this secret was revealed in
this students spell book but did you
know that reading Harry Potter is
actually a good thing for our society a
study found that reading this book makes
you more tolerant towards people who are
different for example they have fewer
prejudices towards immigrants refugees
and members of the LGBT community that's
another great reason to do another Harry
Potter marathon me and Italica when we
learn about how people used to live
thousands of years ago all we can think
of is that we feel sorry for them how
did they survive without the internet
and smartphones and we can't even
believe that they didn't even have
electricity or running water this
student thought that Neanderthals were
probably really bored and this is why he
gave them something to do now they are
playing guitar and drums this is not
Stone Age anymore but rock of age but do
you know when music was invented the
earliest known musical instruments are
just 40,000 years old it seems to be a
lot but it's nothing compared to the
first axe is invented 1.7
years ago but music itself might be
older than the first musical instruments
scientists believe that it was used as a
way to communicate before the invention
of language that would explain why we
love listening to a song even when we
don't understand all the lyrics dead or
alive don't you think that all the
important men in history our teachers
talk about look the same they are all
following the trends of that time and we
rarely see someone who stands out in our
textbooks this is probably why someone
decided to fix this lack of diversity by
turning someone into a famous character
with the hats the big eyes and the
little nose you can easily see that is
Tony Tony chopper and he is wanted dead
or alive we don't understand why this
man made this student think about the
funny character but it's a great idea
and if you don't know who Tony Tony
chopper is you have been missing out he
is the cotton candy lover and doctor of
the straw hat pirates in the anime one
piece and if you are looking for funny
pirates on an adventure to find a
treasure you must watch this show the
gymnasts this time this student was
learning about gymnastics we don't know
how a textbook could be useful to do
something physical but the whole group
had to look at this anyway we have to
admit that what this guy is doing is
really impressive and there is no way we
are going to learn how to do this even
if we read this book several times this
is why the student decided to turn it
into something more realistic he made
the gymnast fall on the floor it
probably hurts to fail after being so
confident but we have to admit that it
is really funny in physical education
class you have probably seen boys and
girls competing in different teams
because our teachers say that men are
stronger but you might be surprised to
learn that women are actually better
survivors than men since the day they
are born and scientists don't even know
why so you can say that next time
someone makes fun of a girl in class
Michael Jackson biology was one of our
favorite classes we loved learning about
our body why it does weird things and
how to be healthier however we don't
think that knowing the name of every
part of our body will ever be useful
unless we want to be a doctor there is
just no way we are going to use these
words ever again after the exam
and this is why someone turned this
picture into something we will remember
forever Michael Jackson if only this
singer wrote a song about biology we
would know those lyrics by heart but we
are still happy that he left us with
great songs like thriller Billie Jean
and blacker white speaking of colors do
you know why Michael was born black but
decided to become white
he actually had vitiligo a disease that
attacks cells that produce melanin and
instead of slowly becoming white and
being two colors at the same time he
decided to make all his skin white but
no matter what he always said that he
was a proud black American the property
if you borrow a textbook at the library
you'll see the name of all the people
who use the book no one usually reads it
but we think it would be worth it this
time because not only one but many
students turned it into something really
funny the first one talked about Jesus
who turned water into wine Michael
Jackson he went from black to white and
uncle ruckus who went from white to
black then another student made a
similar joke with the singer and added
Bruce Jenner who was born a man but had
the courage to say that she felt like a
woman then there's this student who was
inspired by all his favorite superheroes
the Dark Knight spider-man Superman and
Captain America he also drew the
original logos and the new ones wouldn't
it be cool to own a book who used to
belong to one of our favorite
celebrities we hope that they drew some
pictures in these text books too the
group member one of the things that we
hate the most in class is the noise we
don't know how they managed to do that
but the voice of our teachers always
makes us fall asleep they should make
relaxation videos and then even when we
want to listen to them there are other
students talking about random things at
the back of the class and we just can't
focus on what the teacher is saying
wouldn't it be better to just listen to
our favorite artists we could do this
all day this is why the student turned
the people in his textbook into the
members of KISS now that would keep us
captivated and if you want to listen to
music in class we have a little secret
to tell you
put the earbuds up into your shirt in
the long sleeves and tell it is in your
hand then you can just rest your head on
your
and you will be able to listen to the
music just make sure it's not too loud
because if the teacher hears you you'll
hear about it for a long time
Davy Jones we know that we're going to
be having a good day when a teacher
brings a DVD to class it comes with some
drawbacks like having to listen to
something a little too childish or
answer questions to make sure that we
understand the film but sometimes we
also get the best teachers in the world
who show us movies that we all want to
watch and one of them is Pirates of the
Caribbean a student was so inspired that
he turned someone in his textbook into
Davy Jones and we think that it doesn't
have to be a bad thing as it's important
that students work on something that
they love mostly if they want to work in
the film industry and do you want to
know how Davy Jones was created it was
all made by computer and it is actually
really weird to see him in real life we
think that we are even more scared of
the actor with a face like that
we don't wanna there are all kinds of
different kids at school but there is
one thing that we all have in common we
just don't wanna even if we love
learning new things school always starts
too early teachers tell us about useless
stuff and there is always some drama
with other students art is one of the
best therapies and this is why a student
expressed his feelings in a textbook
after reading his chapter he was asked
to answer some questions and he just
drew a character to show that he doesn't
want to but if you want to convince your
school to make things change show them a
study instead scientists prove that
students who are allowed to wake up
later in the morning would be more
focused during the day and less likely
to be late now go tell that to your
teacher next time you feel tired the
footnote sometimes the textbooks are so
boring that even those who write it want
to have fun this is not actually
vandalism but we think that their boss
wouldn't be happy about that so we still
want it to be part of our list this time
the writers who wrote something funny in
the footnote said this chapter might
have been called introduction but nobody
reads the introduction and we wanted you
to read this we feel safe admitting this
here in the footnote because nobody
reads the footnote either they're
probably right because their boss didn't
see it either and it inspires us to see
footnotes in a whole different way just
look at this valley
time it shares a message of love but
only if the person loves them back and
we think that it would be really useful
if we were a little shy and want to make
people laugh we know what it's like to
have a crush in high school
the monster teachers in biology class
might want us to know more about our
body but the only thing they achieved is
making us even more disgusted by it we
already don't feel confident about how
we look on the outside so imagine what
it's like when we see all the veins the
blood and the intestines on the inside
but a student saw another monster in the
human body and it is one giant man with
no skin who is going to attack us
luckily for us a hero is coming to the
rescue and do you want to know some
weird facts about the human body if all
the veins of the human circulatory
system were laid end to end the total
length would be 60,000 miles which is
two and a half times around the earth so
you have no reason to think that you're
not amazing with all these impressive
things inside us the selfie taking a
picture of ourselves is one of the
things that teenagers love to do the
most unfortunately most of us can't use
our smartphone in class and there is
nothing interesting to show anyway this
is why someone reimagined some
historical characters in the 21st
century and gave them iPhones now they
can talk selfies too and the result is
hilarious
the student wasn't only inspired by one
but by many pictures if you don't
believe that selfies are more popular
than ever just look at the stats
Millennials take on average 7 minutes to
take the perfect selfie which makes one
hour a week and a total of 20 5700
selfies in their lifetime at least older
people will have to admit that this is
one thing they are good at
did you ever vandalize a textbook don't
be shy to tell us what you did or what
you would like to do in the comments
section down below we'd love to hear
what you think and that's it for 15
examples of genius textbook vandalism by
bored students that can almost be
forgiven for more stories like this make
sure you watch 15 random acts of
vandalism that are pure genius thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]